[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum how are you Ryan I'm
good nice stash bro thanks man killer
stash that was Mario in a sketch
yesterday so I decided to keep it really
yeah I had a girlfriend what'd she think
she hates it
because they look like a cop you look
like Keith Hernandez I get in yeah from
the Mets I turn in the cop dad
exactly just Dad cop uh guys thanks for
tuning in if you're here for Pete Holmes
and you like the podcast all I ask is if
maybe you could subscribe and write a
review and listen to the podcast uh our
handles are Ryan at inside if you pod on
Twitter outside of your podcast on
Instagram and Facebook that's exactly
right and if you want to join patreon to
support the podcast give back really
helps the podcast it keeps us going our
lovely patrons do that go to patreon.com
inside of you and I will send you a
message thanks for the support uh also
don't forget the inside of you online
store we've got tons of merch Smallville
stuff autographs check it out there's so
many cool things on that go to the
inside of you online store
and that's pretty much it man Pete
Holmes today man he's uh
what so much energy a lot a lot of
energy and just you could just he
reminds me of like a John Ritter like a
little bit of a John Ritter at times
just a great guy he sent me a ton of
bagels this whole platter of bagels and
cream cheese and locks and stuff just
for helping him out with some guests
what a lovely lovely man you know him
from crashing he's done stand-up
specials
very funny guy and a beautiful guy
inside out so without further Ado let's
get inside of Pete Holmes it's my point
of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
um I don't have kids oh you have kid
energy do I have a kid energy I just
assumed you had kids well I guess
because you're seeing all the
memorabilia over my house and no no that
reads single that was are you married no
okay no I'm lonely
I am you look at me like you're sad for
me that's me suppressing a huge laugh
because I love I love honesty yeah I'm
lonely I have uh anxiety I am I'm lonely
how many 3PO heads before you start to
calm down C3PO heads up I said threepio
what do we see that's like usted we're
using two threepio you see three Pete
homes have you ever heard that three
Pete Holmes c3p homes there's your
episode name wow we did a C3 Pete Holmes
I want to get back to your loneliness
but your C3 Pete Holmes t-shirt and we
found out just how quickly the lucasfilm
people
will send you a horse head they don't
send a cease and desist they go full guy
oh god father
head in my bed with a cease and desist
stapled to its forehead I don't know but
they did send you a letter I mean
immediately two T-shirts we did we don't
really do many t-shirts anymore but we
used to do a lot of t-shirts uh when
I've been doing my podcast for 10 years
podcast you made it weird with Kate
Holmes thank you Michael you guys should
listen to it it's really fun very casual
on the couch very open we're on the same
couch yeah
it has a sleepover Vibe some guests We
Touch feet is that true it really is who
have you touched feet with their choice
I couldn't tell you I think me and Maya
Rudolph might have snuggled up feet
really don't tell PTA she seemed very
comfortable in the interview there's
your clickbait Pete Holmes hitting on
Maya Rudolph I was enamored with Maya
what was I about to tell you though so
probably back to my loneliness no
yeah two two intellectual properties
that you don't want to [ __ ] with are you
ready to guess Star Wars Star Wars is
one you'll never guess the second one
let's not even waste time okay Prince
really because Michael Shea did my
podcast and he told a story sorry what
was your name again
that's Ryan I just
I like honesty you do you know there's
it's inbounds five minutes after a
meeting you're allowed to say what was
it again
you got five I turned and Ryan likes you
by the way you get five
six your [ __ ] five dead it's not even
good
more of an Essence impression I like it
I like are you do you always have this
go ahead finish your thought yeah
yeah thank you I'm mad at you I know but
he told a story about being at an SNL
party and Jack Nicholson was there and I
forget who the other person was there
but like big stores right right and then
Prince walked in and he was like and no
one gave a [ __ ] about the other stars
right and we were like wow they got
princed we kept laughing so we made a
t-shirt that said you got princed Jenny
fine the artist that I often work with
who's fantastic follower on the gram uh
she Drew this amazing drawing of Prince
and it said you got Prince and I had
like Jack Nicholson looking sad I think
we sold two before like a handwritten
scroll from Prince's estate I mean who
pays attention to that stuff who finds
it somebody somebody is out there going
like C3 Pete Holmes they're just looking
for season three oh yes they're getting
a lot of C4 for C3 right a lot of a lot
of emails with someone's job it's
someone's job out there I've flown out
of a lot of gates c3s are they just
shutting down
Southwest seasoned desist is this how
your your mind always works like this
doesn't it no I'm gonna be honest with
you Michael and [ __ ] oh no and Ryan
are you lonely too is that what you're
gonna tell me you're not lonely at all
you've got a wife you've got a kid you
live in a Little House on the Prairie
that's a fart noise
um nothing wrong with that nothing wrong
with it it was it was the way I laughed
uh I'm excited to do this bot I've been
looking forward to it I'm excited about
it uh you've got so much going on like I
I get tired I mean act or writer
comedian producer podcaster all three of
a book comedy Sex God you've done tons
of shows you do stand up all the time
your Instagram's full with funny [ __ ] oh
thank you and it's just like I just
asked myself I tell myself I couldn't do
this this is too exhausting for me and
on top of it you're married you have a
kid how do you do oh right I run out
I've got to stop this now I've got to
quit all of it
on a swing somewhere
but how do you not get overwhelmed how
do you not get overwhelmed you know I
that's such a general I feel very
welcome I always forget to do that on my
own podcast is just make the guests feel
appreciated and welcome well I
appreciate it good on you but I really
I'm not just saying this when you put it
all together it sounds like a lot and uh
there's a lot of wonderful people my boy
and my boy Jake
um does my Instagram instant pictogram
he helps you with your your Instagram he
doesn't help me he does it
so you don't have to handle Instagram
for the most part
I think I'm out there logging on to
Instagram you don't you don't think
someone this happy is scrolling you
don't make comments you don't make
comments leave comments things like that
if anyone's getting comment backs that's
Jake [ __ ] with you and I hope he's
not because that's not in the job
description and he's like I think we
should be together Jake
that's not your job that's not your job
lips Jake I have a reputation I'd leave
my family in a heartbeat why is it
Sandler I leave my family in a heartbeat
for you oh that was pretty good at the
end yeah that's how you do impressions
well I do a little bit but but Jake had
to retire that Spacey one oh yeah no
we're not doing that anymore no God damn
it now listen to me that's sweet and low
that's great I haven't done it ages but
look you so you have someone help you
with your Instagram what else do you
have someone help you with I'm glad you
asked because it really is you have an
assistant I do have an assistant I've
had the same assistant for almost
15 years or something like an incredible
amount of time what her name is Paige
executive assistant exactly because
she's she helps with so much more than
just you know she doesn't get my dry
clean I don't do dry cleaning I I don't
either very much right dry cleaning I
don't do dry cleaning oh yeah I did it
yesterday you did dry cleaning I do my
own dry cleaning oh you do your own well
you do your own but I just don't do dry
cleaning if something if it's dry clean
only I go leave that to a Baldwin
um not me but I do have this from Conair
it's a spot from the movie Connor no no
but it's a little uh portable steamer
thing for my my their sponsor yeah wow I
haven't even begun to hit you up for
sponsors you've been helping me with
guests which was so I want it on the
record Ryan yeah Michael
you know what it's like doing a podcast
and I'm sorry no don't but I've been
doing it for 10 years and if there's
anything that is a drag about it and
it's it's only a drag if you let it
atrophy and you just coast and you're
just dropping you had some banked and
they're just dropping and you're just
[ __ ] taking naps and [ __ ] yeah and
then you wake up one day and you go
there's no episode next week and it's
just like being in high school again
it's like kind of scary all this
tomorrow and you're just like it sucks
it's anxiety things that's I get this
anxiety yeah it's also it's worse it
becomes this sort of sweaty desperate I
become the guy that I don't want to be
I'm at a party and I'm like you want to
do my [ __ ] I've seen it's just like God
that's how I feel I feel like I'm
emailing people and I'm like hey would
your friend do it and then would your
friends friends there anything worse
than emailing Kumail your good friend
Kumail and saying even as I say this
Kumail you're right I emailed Camille
right who I've known for 20 years and
he's done your podcast many times many
times he's already that's that's
actually my point Camille's done enough
and I just go hey would you put me in
touch with Dave Batista
superson
on the podcast [ __ ] you [ __ ] me [ __ ]
everybody
I'm giving you Clips up the [ __ ] dude
oh man I'll post him on my gram that's
free [ __ ] to Jake this is ready to pose
this is a real Ryan all right all right
hang on what do you what do you do with
this energy how are you how old are you
yeah 43 43 and you have such a great
energy do you drink I know you're
looking at Friday the 13th that's a
Jason mask but do you are you just do
you have ADD like me it's on it's a big
topic of conversation is whether or not
I have it I I'd wager I guess okay it's
a c and that's not if that's yes same
word uh yes I think I probably have it
but but I don't know how you feel about
it uh I like it
I think I used to like it I think it
kind of took over where oh really I get
anxious about everything anxious about
everything every little thing of
somebody says hey tomorrow we're doing
this it's anxiety hey there's a bachelor
party anxiety I hate planning there's
there's planning and there's like you
know it's like when am I gonna have time
how could I do this am I gonna yeah
you're actually making me realize I
don't like it but I'm very I I mean that
real like I'm very I'm doing what I'm
doing for the most part but that's bad
because if you're worrying then I'm
really doing what I'm doing and we're
back to what we were just talking about
which is like if I don't have a guest
that just becomes my reality I'm not a
multitask person I like to do two things
me too me too if there's three things at
Don you can't do it [ __ ] you I can't
I'll cancel it yeah it could be dinner
with Bono yeah oh has he done the [ __ ]
I'm actually chasing Bono but you get
some good guests I do yeah and a lot of
that is um is just being out being out
and and and and seeing you for example
you'd be a great guest I would I would
be a lovely guest let's podswap
stocking but not with our dick
I don't have a foreskin anyway I have a
fives again there's a lot of it it's
like a sleeve it's like a it's not a
turtleneck it's just like a tube have
you always been this way since you're a
kid
yeah I really want to stress this I'm in
a very good mood because as I said as it
came in I was like I love it I'm already
ingratiated to you you seem so kind oh
this is what I wanted to get on the
record I email you I'm in a panic I
mailed Rich Roll too rich roll was very
sweet you know Rich another great shout
out Camille did not give me Dave
Batista's email that's where we were
which by the way
fair play to you yeah that is not this
is not shots fired right but I don't
like being the guy as I hit send on the
email I was like what am I doing you
know what I mean yeah just don't have
Dave Batista on right now yeah don't hit
up Kumail don't bother how many times
did you ask him about Dave Batista once
you should go twice email him again I
would just say hey I'm not gonna I'm
gonna end it right here I'm not gonna
email it on my mind after this I'm gonna
moonwalk into a lake that's what I said
there you go it's a funny way of saying
we're walking away last email jumping
into a list uh
um but but I anyway the point is maybe
hashtag Bautista just at the end of it
keep it light keep it light I think
we're similar people yeah but you and
Rich Roll and and a couple other people
um and Judd is like this jet is very
shut up who I was on the phone with
today and he said I said I'm going my
way to do your podcast and he said
please tell them he's a Swedish tell him
I said um
you know if you could quit the promote
the bubble that would be great yeah that
was that was a terrible gem but it was
fine it was fine it was fine
inside he was brought to you by athletic
greens Ryan I don't know
what I would do without athletic greens
I have uh I hate taking pills I hate
taking vitamins
a lot of times you're uh they give you
powders that taste crappy that you mix
and you have to hold your nose the way
you drink them and finally
there's a company called athletic greens
that makes something that's actually
delicious to drink easy you do it in the
morning it's got like 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
ingredients probiotics and adaptogens
these are the things that you know
doctors tell me I need to do I need more
of this I need more of that
and for a while I would get all these
pills and I forget to take them and I
know are they really working I don't I
feel like I take a glass of this
athletic greens it's so easy in the
morning
and I just feel better you do it for
like it took me like a you know within a
week I started noticing my energy levels
were a little better and they got better
and better and I feel like you just feel
like hey I'm doing everything good for
my body
um I think it's really important they
have so many good things
um in this athletic greens and uh you
know
seven thousand five star reviews
uh recommended by professional athletes
trusted by Leading Health experts
uh it's it's just it's a great great
thing to be doing to your for your body
and I'm gonna have to give you some of
this stuff yeah yeah because I they sent
me stuff and it's good and they also
sent my my buddy Tom Welling who just
loves it he texted me the other day and
welling's you know Welling for my other
podcast talk Ville and he's just going
off on it he's like man this this stuff
is actually really good it tastes good
too well it's good enough for Tom it's
good enough for me there you go if it's
good enough for Welling we both really
uh enjoy it uh athletic greens is a
climate neutral certified company in
2020 athletic greens purchased carbon
credits that support projects protecting
old growth rainforests it's just a great
company
um they're not only doing good for the
environment in the world they're doing
good for people like us
um whether you eat keto paleo vegan
dairy free or gluten-free
um it's lifestyle friendly athletic
greens contains less than one gram of
sugar no GMOs No nasty chemicals or
artificial anything while still tasting
good it's the one thing with the best
things athletic greens uses some of the
best of the best products based on the
latest science with constant product
iterations and third-party testing it's
just one scoop in a cup of water
every day
that's it
no need for a million different pills or
supplements it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills or supplements
you know I tend especially in late
Mornings in the middle afternoon I get
the brain fog and I just you know I feel
like after taking athletic greens I feel
like I'm just clear
I could think
easier
um and it just gives me energy it's just
uh I mean you've seen me drink it you
see me Stir It Up it's so quick and easy
it's just like
you know I I put it right next to my
sink so in the morning when I wake up I
just go right there let's do this we're
doing this it's become a habit and it's
a good habit
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you one year free supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
come on all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
i o y again that's athleticgreens.com
i o y get some now a word from our
sponsor betterhelp
better help I don't know what we do
without better help uh you know I have
been lately dealing with a lot of
anxiety and what happens is I hyper
focus on all these negative things Ryan
that keep spiraling and I can't I can't
it's hard to focus it's and it exhausts
me and gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and I
know it's not I shouldn't be thinking
all these things and I it's like in my
mind I can't put it to rest a lot of
times
and um
you know it can be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode and you know especially when you're
facing challenges in life and I know
that therapy helps that talking to
someone and having them talk to you
objectively about what works train
professionals helps it just does I doing
it on my own isn't working it's just not
working
if I don't have someone to talk to I
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out that's how I feel
do you feel that way yeah
um you have to talk to somebody you know
people always say well how'd you get
into therapy it's because I just
couldn't solve these problems on my own
I couldn't you know it's you could say
you're going to do these things and
you're saying oh you what happens is you
just bottle stuff up folks we just
bottle things up until it becomes very
toxic and our body feels it
physiologically we feel the effects of
you know pain depression anxiety and it
takes a toll on your mind and your body
and that is why I got into therapy and
I'll tell you A lot of times I have
nothing to talk about and for the first
five minutes like why am I here what am
I doing and by the end of it I'm like
thank God I'm talking to somebody my
Lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option Ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists any time
um you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read to me this is the easiest read
ever because it's just something I could
talk about forever and
um look better help is is a great place
it's a it's a place to to help a lot of
people when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
inside of you is brought to you by Magic
spoon if you haven't tried magic spoon
yet I gotta keep bugging you about it
you really need to give this stuff A
shot cereal that's good for you doesn't
have to suck Ryan it just needs a little
magic and that's magic spoon you know
when we're younger
we can eat whatever we want when your
kids eat all those sugary cereals and
all that but then as adults like oh I
can't eat cereal anymore because it's
all no you can and that's what magic
spoon is all about we're able to now
enjoy cereal as adults with magic spoon
uh Magic spoon has replicated your
favorite childhood cereals to taste good
and be good for you each serving
contains zero grams of sugar over 13
grams of protein and less than 5 grams
of net carbs it's a low carb keto
friendly gluten-free grain free and soy
free way to relive those moments
watching your favorite cartoons plus
it's only 140 calories a serving it's
like there's magic in every spoonful
there sure is Ryan with over eight
unique flavors you will not get bored of
feeling good with magic spoon I've got
some flavors that I particularly love I
love cocoa I love fruity and I love
peanut butter but the frost is good
blueberry muffin Maple waffle honey nut
cookies and cream and cinnamon roll
this stuff is delicious
um I love it my friends love it and you
will absolutely love this head to
magicspoon.com
IOU to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try the magic for yourself and be
sure to use our promo code IOU at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and Magic spoon Ryan is so
confident in their product it's backed
with 100 happiness guarantee you don't
see this with cereals or most of any
food say look if you don't like it for
any reason they're going to refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com IOU and use the
code IOU to save five dollars off thank
you magicspoon for sponsoring this
podcast
yes I liked and I loved Jen he was a
great guest and he's very gay but he's
literally one of my best friends that
I'm saying that fully aware of how weird
that is you created a show crash and he
directed it he believed in you you
created friends yeah you direct the
pilot you're you're the co-creator
co-creator yeah perhaps and it was and I
say this to compliment him it was his
show a lot of things my life did not win
like I couldn't Trump and go like but
that's not what happened Judd would be
like like there's a great example of
Judd's genius really I'm done kissing
his ass you'd know if I was kissing his
ass I mean it you know what I mean right
there's a way where you're like it's
genius please call me back you know it's
not that right it's a good example I
feel like I didn't need to step that out
you were a little bored no no I'm not
bored at all what happened you were like
get to it subtitles on no I'm listening
intently
there was a scene where I worked at this
place called the Boston Common Club I
really did and we rebuilt it for the for
the um for HBO crashing why I say HBO
and it was an exact replica of this club
that used to exist in New York it was
crazy wow Sarah Silverman walked on and
she started crying we were doing that
all the time we rebuilt rafifi Eugene
Merman and Bobby Tisdale walked on Bobby
started crying like it was just like
imagine if the place you grew up doing
because I rebuilt was torn down and then
we rebuilt it and then we shot scenes
pretending it was still like it was very
emotional but we did the scene
where I was I grew up religious so like
when I started doing comedy I was very
clean
um and I like that all my heroes were
Seinfeld Ray Romano Ellen Gallagher I
actually liked Galaxy I did too okay
Gallagher's mad as hell Gallagher's mad
and I'm sorry that was from up special
buddy if I knew it
would be doing a two-part round right
now three that's up to Rye yep
um but
I I had scripted a little bit in my
favor meaning the episode was my parents
are in town and they unannounced decide
to show up at the Boston Comedy Club to
watch me this never happened but had it
happened
I would have been the only clean one the
Boston was it was a den of Thieves it
was Pirates it was like it was crazy
right and I was like Jack McBrayer just
like the sweet I know I love the
sweetest the sweet man I bet he's done
your podcast no he can't he I don't
think he'll do a podcast I think he
Dodges them too he Dodges them one time
we were at The Improv and I was like he
was like what's your what's your podcast
about and I was like well you know it's
kind of like a you share everything
about your life and he was like no thank
you
come out and then he fixed my Felix
right what does that mean I just wanted
to reference Fix It Felix it sounded
sexual I didn't mean it to anyway so my
parents come everyone's doing like we
the whole point was people are doing
like jizz jokes and stuff like that real
dirty real dirty and you're the only
clean guy and then I go up and I wanted
it to end on this happy note that my mom
is like oh Petey sweetie that was
tremendous everyone else was filth but
you're my golden child why she misses
Doubtfire I don't know but um my mom
sort of talked like that she's
Lithuanian she's Lithuanian but she
talks a little bit like that not like
Boston too but anyway
and then Judd was like he really taught
me something and this is really you ever
give something some somebody something
your therapist told you and you're like
this cost me ten thousand dollars I'm
telling you what to do this is like ten
thousand dollars worth of Show Business
advice right because he was like and
he's so right
uh entertainment's all about surprise
everyone thinks your parents are gonna
like you and not like the dirty people
he was like your mom should be like at
least they had something to say like you
were up there talking about road signs
oh my God it's this satisfying moment
right and it's such a simple principle
but that's one of the that's really ten
thousand dollars worth of appetite right
there is if you're writing a script and
the great shows that I watch I'm
watching Oroville right now I really
think Oroville is great just a little
bit I haven't seen it it's very good uh
they do that all the time it's digging
when you might want to zag like oh of
course he's gonna take her back or
whatever and he doesn't right and that's
why we watch Breaking Bad it's like and
then he doesn't and then he kills the
person or whatever it is right you want
to be surprised you want to be surprised
so anyway sorry that was a bit no were
your uh
did did you go to Judd Apatow with
crashing did you bring it to him you're
an Apatow man how did you did you how
did that happen
toe yeah did you bring the script to him
he got it to him or did he like your
comedy did he know you I'm gonna tell
you I can do I can do the story quickly
okay but I think it's a fantastic story
and I left thinking about it because it
it makes my heart open with gratitude
any of this happened but what happened
was I was doing a talk show called The
Pete home show which was my first really
big break right at other breaks but JP
Buck who I'm still indebted to and very
grateful for he was the comedy Booker on
Conan he kept whispering in Conan's ear
like I think the speed homes guy would
be good to host this uh a late night
show right if you wanted a protege or he
just wanted to give a kid a shot I I
can't know another man's mind and you
were you were kind of friendly with
Conan at this point
once and they were already Whispering
Your Praises well that's they wanted
someone unknown they didn't want it
wasn't I'm saying uh Wayne Brady because
Wayne Brady had a talk show I'm not
teasingly right right I didn't want the
Wayne Brady show they wanted like who
the [ __ ] is this guy which believe it or
not that's what it was when Conan was on
literally like all caps who the [ __ ] is
this guy that's when he when he first
did the Conan O'Brien show back in the
90s I was a regular recurring sketch
comedy guy oh wow and I did the
Amsterdam kids two kids who were
misinformed about Amsterdam's liberal
social policies and I did like seven
episodes I have them on tape still and
you get paid a couple hundred bucks and
go on and nobody was watching Conan
nobody knew Conan yeah they were waiting
for it to go away yeah and by today's
standards it would have yes
inside you is brought to you by Conair
uh you know what I hate going to the dry
cleaners I'm flying a lot Ryan I go all
over the place and my clothes are always
wrinkled
but not anymore Ryan no not anymore uh
the Conair turbo extreme steam Steam and
iron two in one it's the most powerful
handheld steamer it's so easy to use and
so small you could pack it in your bag
and travel with it and you never have to
worry about wrinkly dinkly clothes not
anymore fast and easy wrinkle removal
extra large sole plate can be used
vertical or horizontal also works
without steam as a dry iron advanced
heat technology is ready almost
instantly and obliterates wrinkles with
turbocharged dry steam four settings for
delicate to Turbo is perfect for all
Fabrics kills 99.9 percent of all
bacteria sanitizes around the house and
refreshes clothing easy to use great for
at home or on the go to get yours today
go to Amazon and search Conair turbo
extreme Steam and look for the Steam and
iron two in one inside of you is brought
to you by First Alert it's fire
prevention month folks did you know a
fire department responds to a fire every
23 seconds we have teamed up with First
Alert the most trusted brand in fire
safety to help protect your whole home
with safety you can trust smoke and
carbon monoxide alarms help provide an
early warning in the event of a home
emergency having enough First Alert
smoke and carbon monoxide alarms is one
of the best things you can do for your
home and your family install alarms on
every level and in every bedroom of your
home now once alarms are installed it's
important to maintain them by testing
them regularly also remember alarms
don't last forever and need to be
replaced at least every 10 years they
are on duty 24 7. if you cannot remember
the last time you replaced your alarm
it's best to replace the unit completely
for a replacement option my favorite is
first alerts 10-year sealed battery
alarms 10-year sealed battery alarms are
convenient and eliminate the need for
battery replacements for a decade along
with alarms fire extinguishers are
essential make sure to place fire
extinguishers on every level and in
common spaces like the kitchen and know
how to use them for more information on
Fire Safety Products safety tips and
educational activities you can do at
home with your family visit
firstalert.com
fire prevention month first alert.com
slash fire prevention month
it's actually Conan was being renewed
week by week at a certain point by ABC
which I think is really brutal oh that's
a good story
so they're whispering in your ear though
I don't want to forget that there's an
element yeah JP Buck Right deserves so
much of this credit so does Jeff Ross
Conan's producer not the rose comedian
anyway I do I'm writing on a multicam on
the Warner Brothers lot and I walk over
to do stand-up on Conan show I don't
know anything about the about the them
looking for a late night host I would
have been terrified I'm glad I didn't
know right but I went out and I did my
second Conan set and this is about 50
pounds lighter than my first Conan set
first Conan set is fun to look up the uh
my Google set I'm I'm 280 like it's a
lot it's like 270 maybe it's a lot I'm
like 235 right now oh really imagine
imagine 280. wow big guy big boy big boy
fun boy fun boy
anything where the name of the dish is
is the recipe I was eating it uh so
anyway the reason I mentioned that is I
I had a good breakup I needed to break
up with somebody I stopped drinking as
much as the juice fast for 30 days like
a real L.A wow okay and then got like my
skin was glowing did Conan then that's a
whole other story uh but Judd did a
sketch for the Pete home show as it was
called we just Nick Bernstein our
producer I think just was like it would
be funny if maybe we could get Judd
Apatow maybe you pitch him a movie like
a fake movie or something that's the gag
right by the way now having known Judd
for so long that's everyone's gag like
yeah every day people are calling
hey uh it's key and peel what if we
pitch your fake you know that that's a
bad example but you know what I mean
like any any comedy show that's the gag
you do with Chad so we do it and he he
keeps we're improvising he keeps going
like but what's your real idea what'd
you really do in the sketch
and in the sketch I pitch him crashing
you can see it it's on YouTube I pitch
him crashing he's like what did you say
what was the what was the pitch and I
said
because I'm still trying to be funny
right like because it's a sketch I go
like what about a story about a guy who
grew up religious who got married when
he was 22 his wife left him when he was
28 and then he was really sad for a
while but he kind of like this is what I
would say now it's definitely not what I
said at the time but he sort of fell
into the arms of Comedy like comedy sort
of rescued him and uh I think what I
said in the sketch was like but then he
gets happy and has sex with a bunch of
women or something which isn't even true
but you get what right and he was like
and in the sketch he goes I think that's
just too sad that's too sad so he's he's
riffing too so a few months later uh the
Pete home show has canceled the funny
thing about that is we were on the air
for three four more months or something
because we filmed so many back episodes
right we used to shoot Nine episodes in
a week it was insane not always but our
heaviest weeks were nine in a week and
the only four would air
you know Monday through Thursday every
night so we had a lot of episodes so I
knew it was canceled but Hollywood and
the world did not know it was canceled
do you deal with rejection well by the
way little
better yeah it's interesting because I
just had a show canceled recently and I
was a CBS show my CBS show was canceled
my our CBS show was canceled and that
was actually harder
um than it was back then because now
you're sort of like you have your family
and all these things but back then
when a show was canceled I felt like a
pirate a second pirate reference and I
put a knife between my teeth and I'd
grab a rope on a burning boat and I'd
swing to another boat like there was
this great really yeah yeah I get Juiced
by a No in fact a no is a I I think the
the Geniuses of the world know this and
this is why I think people like Judd for
example I don't know if he does it for
for real but like Elon Musk or whatever
these these high functioning uh people
right I think they know that and they
try to manufacture situations where they
fail intentionally this is a theory
because there's no fuel like a no that's
sort of like oh you think you're gonna
stop me [ __ ] you know like
there's no substitute for that you can
go like it'd be fun to sell a show
that's okay that's like 30 right Tesla
charge but if you want to get like a
full road trip you gotta get like
for me I gotta get like oh
they think I I stink or they they're not
they think they can stop me that gives
you fuel it can give you like a really a
a less sexy or sensationalized way to
say it it gives you this desperation
that you really sort of need really for
sure and that happened so I I don't
think that happens with everybody I
probably these people can really fold
and really get upset and really go
through a dark time when things happen
like that and I agree I'm a little bit
more you're lucky I'm a little bit more
that way now when How We Roll got
canceled I I had because I'm also more
embodied I'm a little bit more
thoughtful a little bit more honest with
my feelings so I'll spend the time to
like mourn something right which back
then I'd be like just keep moving like
Dad you know what I mean be like Dad
feel nothing you know just just keep
running towards the next stop yeah
um but luckily I did that was the right
thing to do for me at that time so
here's the story P Dome show gets
canceled me and my producer and partner
uh who's wonderful Oren Bremer we still
work together we're like what what
should we do that we have a little bit
of a name now uh let's go to Comedy
Central and we'll pitch them a sketch
show because so much of what made the
pedome show popular was the sketches so
we're like will be the pop culture
sketch show their key and peel was on at
the time but there was nobody doing just
like we do in Indiana Jones or Friday
the 13th we love that stuff Star Wars we
love that stuff so we'll be the pop
culture sketch show Kent alterman who
was the was love Kent was the head of
Comedy Central Time uh we're in a
meeting just like this just like the
three of us except orange here and uh in
the small talk that sort of Swedish 10
minutes where you just kind of shoot the
[ __ ] because nobody just wants to start
like here's the idea imagine Luke
Skywalker but he works out of Supercuts
like nobody wants to start like that you
start with how are you right
in that 10 minutes we're about to pitch
a sketch show Kent Alderman says just
offhandedly as a joke he goes well one
thing's for sure we don't want another
[ __ ] sketch show and everyone laughs
and I'm like
[Music]
that's what I'm gonna pinch you
not anymore if there was a shredder if
there was a barrel fire in the room I
would have tossed the deck really so you
just aborted we mid meeting
just said we just wanted to check in and
see what you guys are up to and like
just didn't pitch it
he probably was like I thought it was a
pitch meeting we didn't pitch it we left
here's the best part though so this is
kind of a no and pirate knife right Rope
Rope burning
PD
goes in the car third person
just talking
right now Ryan just like a like a real
uh right in the ding
but I'm I'm real desperate and I'm real
it's not even for like
you know like it wasn't like how am I
gonna eat it was more like what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do like like an existential
like what is my life gonna be and I and
I said
it's one of those great little moments
um where you go okay
if you could do anything anything what
could you do and I don't want to be too
woo-woo but I think I I'm not even a
believer necessarily in like the hard
secret or manifesting or anything but I
am a big big Capital case uppercase
believer and if you can't see it no one
else is going to see it first you have
to see it right you want to be Harrison
Ford you have to go like I want to be
Harrison Ford I'm not saying that's
going to make it happen but if you can't
see yourself on manifest
sort of right green lighted you green
light at first because if you don't I
think you're going to unconsciously be
sabotaging yourself or limiting yourself
right you have to 100 believe in what
you're saying
at least take a second to ask yourself
if you can't see yourself on the Raiders
poster
why and maybe clean that up
um maybe mommy loved you too much maybe
she loved you not enough but something
went funky fix that yeah so in the car I
I had enough self-love to go like let's
be real what would you do if you could
do anything and I think that's a really
important question it's that high school
guidance counselor question and I said
I'm obsessed with Chad Apatow my whole
life like for real I know everybody
loves shed but like 40 year old virgin
meant a lot to me Knocked Up meant even
more to me I started getting divorced
when This is 40 was out if you recall uh
Paul Rudd's character in that movie is
named Peter and Leslie Mann tearfully is
like wondering if she's gonna stay with
Peter and I'm like I'm sitting next to
my wife who is cheating on me and I'm
like
yeah yeah I know we're seeing a [ __ ]
jet movie
helping it's helping me through
something that I don't even know is
about to happen wow
and I'm and I love girls and the TV show
girls I was like wait what I love girls
non-sequitur I enjoy girls okay all
right no I love the TV show Girls
I do love women I I I tend to get along
with women good for you better than men
I didn't just mean sexual ages yeah as
people yeah
um uh you're in the car oh yeah so I go
thank you I go I would do an HBO show
like girls 30 minute drama comedy this
is on a Wednesday
I had Judd's assistant or somebody's
email from when he did the penome show
six months earlier
and I emailed Josh church and email Josh
church and I go hey Josh uh I have an
idea for Judd
um does he have 15 minutes for me and
they're they're like yeah but we're in
New York shooting Trainwreck
I wish I had more stories like this
because this is such a fun story I like
this song so far it's down in the dumps
yeah but I'm doing all this almost in a
fit of mania like I am today I'm manic
today but not not many bipolar I just
mean I'm very flared up yeah so I'm
emailing Josh and he's like he can see
you Friday morning uh we're on like 26th
and 10th or something they're they're in
New York wow the fact that he made time
for you so soon yes but they didn't I
don't think he knew that I was in LA and
I was just like I'll see you there you
got on a plane I flew out the next day I
didn't even have to pitch
oh I left out the key part before I
emailed I thought
okay what's interesting about me I'm a
raise religious and I'm divorced that's
fine you you tell me you have a show you
want to do about that I'm like okay
you're 70 of the way there and then I
went and when my wife leaves me I have
nowhere to stay but I stay with a
different comedian every episode and I
go now we have what's called an engine
there's there's a repeatable pattern
whether or not you do that that's how
you sell a pilot because you plant in
the executive's mind oh I can see how
this is something with legs right right
so once I had that epiphany of like [ __ ]
and we call it crashing right literally
like writing it on the airline napkin
real cliche wow flew to the center not
even knowing what you're going to talk
about and coming up with it on the way
on the floor yeah writing it out I wish
I had that napkin I get to the set of
train wreck they're shooting in the
magazine office Vanessa Bayer is there
um the kid who plays The Flash is there
um and Amy is there of course and I know
Amy a little bit so I'm talking with Amy
and then at some point they call cut and
they take a break and I get 10 I think
it was 10 12 minutes to pitch uh
crashing and I wasn't I'm better at
pitching now but I wasn't really good at
it but luckily Judd liked it he was
getting into stand-up at the time like
getting back into doing it so pitching a
stand-up origin story to a guy who's
going through his second stand-up words
and also frankly knowing what I know now
Judd wanted to be with comedians he
wanted to be doing sets he wanted to do
a comedy tour to promote her all this
stuff so it was right were you nervous
when you when you were pitching him yeah
I didn't I let's say the meeting I think
I met him at like seven I was probably
about five did he say let's get on with
it right away like no Small Talk was
there any small Tucker thingless Small
Talk they're never was like a okay so
imagine a little show called crash but
it wasn't like but at this point your
wife hadn't divorced you yet you you
weren't cheated on yet oh no no no this
is this is years after that oh years
after that so the whole cheating thing
this is many years after I got divorced
when I was 28. and at this point I am 30
4 were you absolutely depressed and just
crushed when that happened I love that
you're steering it back to a more
relatable area for you yeah were you
lonely were you lonely
I need somebody to relate to me I would
love to relate to you that's the story
but I can can I say one more thing to
that no please I love this go the best
part is to me is Judd didn't say yes you
know what he said he said write 15 pages
a purge it felt like a challenge I'm an
Enneagram why my wing is four I don't
know if you know what that is I kind of
kind we love our own pain okay three is
the achiever that's my main number but I
have a four Wing which means I love
Radiohead you know what I mean like I I
love sad stuff the national is my
favorite band I love the national
when he really do the podcast I I when I
was like asking you I was like who's
easy who's like a friend he's easy Matt
is it my friend and Mark duplos is easy
and Mark duplex but he won't be back in
town until uh remember I have a note yes
I I believe I love Mark did you see
creep the creep movies oh my God they're
so good okay
I [ __ ] love it okay so go back so he
right he goes it's a challenge he goes
write 15 pages of or maybe it's 10 but
he was like just write everything you
remember about being divorced and I was
writing about losing my erection while I
was masturbating like you ever been so
sad that you can't jerk off course but
that was sleep jerking off yeah that's a
little different yeah that's a different
kind of giving up this was like I don't
even want me you know and again like you
can't even but you I really sidebar you
really realize when I got divorced there
was even a part of me because I liked
jerking off so much I was like oh I can
just jerk off all the time like what's I
had never really been single right uh
and it turns out sex and drinking off
her completely different things you know
like you need a body like you want a
body you want as Jackie Novak Jacqueline
Novak says you want the hug of it you
know right jerking off is just released
yeah but I was like I'll just do this
and I was like after a while I was like
you're pushing it's like the engine on
the Enterprise you're really pushing the
limits of how much you can self-soothe
this way right but I put all the most
embarrassing stuff in there that I could
muster my mom kisses me on the lips all
that sort of stuff and I think I so I
met him and I sent it to him like the
next day and then I also he was telling
me stand-up premises and I also sent
them in the car to the airport the next
morning I just rode out tags and like
just like kind of manically being like
hey you know that baby pitched me here's
like and he wrote back I'll never forget
he wrote back this is the nicest thing
anyone's ever done for me I was like
okay I think we're becoming friends and
then he's when he read the pilot I wrote
a pilot
after the document and I rewrote that
pilot I think six or seven times with
different people so not just a rewrite
but like what if it was Hannibal what if
it was Amy Schumer what if it was you
know all none of them were already it
ended up being already linked but that I
wrote it and I was so young and hungry
and didn't have a baby to be honest I I
would trade my baby for all of this but
like when you don't have a baby I can
write a script in a couple days all
right and now it's it's a little bit
harder but anyway
there was all of this Mr miyagiang and
you didn't instill it wasn't a yes we're
doing this it still wasn't a yes right
but he was asking and I was doing and it
was real it was also mixing metaphors it
was very like uh Charles Sims incentive
woman and he was Frank Slade uh Slade
slate uh he was Pacino right
people who know me know I'm tempted to
do my Pacino but
anyway that's that's the story of of
crashing more or less wow yeah and when
you found out that show was getting
picked up was that just
one of the highlights your life it was
it was really great I remember the
second season got picked up while I was
recording a podcast with Valerie who
became my wife uh but we were we
actually paused the podcast to take the
phone call so there's there's some
episode out there I think it's me her
and Brent will you get the call on the
podcast but you don't hear it we weren't
we should have left it in I don't know
what we were doing wow I guess I didn't
know if I could announce it yet or
something but you can tell my mood
elevates mid episode like really and
when the pilot got picked up I jumped on
our couch like I stood up and jumped on
our catch and I broke it you broke the
couch and I kept it for a while because
I was just the happiest break it was
like right I jumped on this couch like
Tom Cruise and broke it wow um and out
of happiness and there's a there's a
Bruce Springsteen
uh he's a friend I'm kidding he he said
oh he's been on the podcast no God that
wouldn't that wouldn't kill me some
people are crazy for Bruce right right
I'm more of a I don't know I don't know
I'm a little Tunnel of Love fan into
this Tunnel of Love Money
don't take Fame I'm doing the mashup
don't need no credit card I'm mashing
them up
go together Huey Lewis did my podcast
okay did he really he did he was great
dude I Love Huey anyway anyway I could
get you Huey could you yes I don't think
I don't know if he'll do it but I'll do
I can get to you I don't know if we'll
do it no way because he lives in I think
he lives I don't want to say where he
lives but it could be uh right it could
be just a uh you know Zoom happy to do
it oh God you're wonderful I'll keep
getting you oh you know you want Henry
Winkler you want Henry Henry is a three
and a half hour episode of my podcast
one of the best oh he came on one of the
best isn't he just gorgeous what a
lovely man I know I think that of you I
think you know I say this every once in
a while about a guest but it seems like
a lot of people like you like you're
you're innately just a good person
what is is does that come from your
roots does that come from the the
religion and the spirituality and the
growing up and all that is that is that
kind of implanted in you or keep
thinking that's Eminem but it's you it's
me it's yeah it's like Eminem yeah thank
you it looks like modern Eminem okay
flight jacket I'll take it unzipped you
also look a little bit like a skinhead
oh that's not good I like it I'm into it
I Vibe with all of them I'm just kidding
I'm totally joking I know I used to go
to punk shows and the skin you had a
punk band skins as they were known a
little bit how are you in a punk band
when you were religious because there's
no Outlet if you don't have an outlet
for your the feelings that you have in
high school you start a punk bed
so while I'm with you yes and especially
today I'm in a very good mood and very
what it really is is you just feel like
your brain is there fully accessible you
know I like it right that's how I feel
today but um there's times when old PD
gets I just want to say this like I get
tired you get moody do you get cranky do
you snap what happens when I snap is and
I talk to Val about this I was like I
tell everyone that I'm fine and I don't
need anybody right that's my thing I'd
rather like go in the back and work
alone even when we were doing crashing
I'd be in the room but then like for the
most part I'd like to hear what they're
saying and then I'd like to go and write
the script Alone
um so I'm always yelling I can do it I
don't need any help and then one day
let's say I do that for a couple months
I go I need some [ __ ] help that's
what I do with you I was like can you
help me wow so that's a pattern I'm
trying to fix is this like grotesque
autonomy does it build up inside you do
you feel things building building
building you're not releasing them and
then you snap and my snap just because
I'm so afraid of my own anger if I'm
being really you could be really angry
well because I'm afraid of my anger I'm
going out of my way to tell you that I
don't get angry I'm terrified of like
I'm not terrified you stay you stay away
from your anger I don't no but I don't I
don't think anyone's seen me get angry
have you seen yourself get angry yeah in
the car I like that like lose your [ __ ]
hit the dashboard no
that would be great I bet that would be
great that'd be a release yeah I've told
this story before but me and Chris there
we did shows together for many years we
once screamed in the car together we
were screaming the song from the
Listerine commercials
[Applause]
but they used it for uh
Tarzan swinging and it was that and we
it was one of it's one of my happiest
memories because if you don't have
somewhere and this is what I'm trying to
do now you have to have modalities to
let
these things that I was taught are in
polite anger jealousy greed lust
whatever bitterness
pettiness
um
and this is hard for like I might not
have felt this way two days ago but like
today from the perspective I'm looking
at myself now I'm like those things are
lovely too it's okay to love your anger
that's what I've been doing lately is I
get this it's usually when I'm under
stress I'm feeling pressure things
aren't coming in whatever it may be and
like we were saying at the beginning I'm
very tunnel vision so if there's nothing
in that tunnel vision it takes a lot of
effort to go like but don't don't forget
there's these things and you know you're
okay but all I see in the tunnel is
nothing coming in and I can get stressed
and that's when I can get angry and what
I've been doing with my anger lately and
I learned this from spiritual name drop
ramdath but he said to me I love my
anger and I've been doing that lately so
my anger shows up
there it is like the ghost of Bill Burr
just shows up in you and I go I love you
it it's crazy how it works you say I
love you I say I love my I love my anger
and I go I see you
I hear you you're welcome I know you're
protecting me I know you care about me
this is coming from a good place a
self-preservational place and and
Valerie my wife uh she's a mindfulness
teacher she's wonderful really and she
yeah and she talks about like feelings
are like children and if you ignore them
if there's a kid running up to you and
being like hey Michael I go mango and
you ignore him
it's worse you need to kind of like so
that's what I do with my anger you I I
see you I feel you you're welcome here
it's a it's a great spiritual technique
is if I feel this way the rest of my
life that's okay do you do it out loud
oh sure if you want do you do it in
front of people I'll do it in the mirror
I'll look in the mirror and go if I feel
this way the rest of my life that's okay
and one of the great I'll summarize my
whole book I'll save you the twenty
dollars or whatever sucks God comedy sex
god
it's it's so many spiritual Traditions
have this but the practice of
non-resistance so you're feeling uh
Panic or or dread and I understand there
are levels of panic uh that I don't
understand that might require other
things but if you're dealing with your
everyday five and dime
Panic or dread or whatever it is
I'll just say this for me your nervous
system your mind everything has no idea
what to do if you say uh yes thank you
to it so the example I I often give is
when my book was sent out to review to
be reviewed they sent uh like the second
draft or something like like there had
been like three drafts since that and
for some reason like books they were
printed as books and in the document
were like notes to myself there were I
put the word Flapjacks in Long documents
so I can search for the word Flapjacks
so I can go back to an area that needs
work such as as Flapjacks in it like
just telling some story about my wife
leaving me flapjacks
like they're gonna think I'm insane I
also didn't know that my book wasn't
going to be reviewed by the New York
Times version I'm I'm thinking the New
York Times is like reading it being like
this guy is a flapjack nut
um but
I remembered what I wrote In the book so
there I was going I was feeling this
like you know what it feels like it
feels like pop rocks it's just like
sadness anger all of these unpleasant
yeah like feelings yes and it didn't go
away until I went oh right remember what
you wrote In the book and I went yes
thank you if I feel this way the rest of
my life it's okay and it doesn't make
any sense and so many of the best things
in life make no sense like your brain
wants to run the show but sometimes you
got to give it to the heart and let the
heart just go
I'll eat it all I'm so [ __ ] alive I'm
[ __ ] freaking out right now and I
[ __ ] love it [ __ ] Pour Some Sugar
On Me You gnarled [ __ ] like just like
look at it like you're an alien that
just wanted to have a human experience
and B I'm not making fun of you you be
lonely in your beautiful memorabilia
house and just go like [ __ ] Michael is
so lonely right now yeah I can do it you
call me
four out of ten times I want you to know
six out of ten maybe it won't work so
don't feel alone if it doesn't work but
sometimes it works
it often works
it's very inspirational isn't it keep it
crispy do you do things do you do things
to help your health every day are there
certain things that are part of a
routine there's a there's a woman
[ __ ] what's her [ __ ] it doesn't
matter anyway there's somebody that was
like if I don't exercise every day like
when you get older again I'm 43.
when you get older you realize there are
certain things that like keep you in the
state and as performers I think we're a
little bit more attuned because it's
your job to be on set and be in a
certain space
uh I'm now only literally
just figuring out I'll say in the past
10 years
what the things are that you need to do
physically and and if I may
and I just throw up dry chairs yeah dry
Cheerios these are did you have Cheerios
this morning no oh okay that'd be weird
though yeah no I don't I've never had
Cherry this is my first time wow why are
you barfing Cheerios tastes great
um what I was gonna say was I never
understood exercise for real
uh until
Valerie said something and it's on a
Post-It above my Tre my treadmill
brag but there's a Post-It and it says
Let the Body solve what the mind can't
and I was like oh my [ __ ] this is like
another way of saying Let Your Heart
Take the reins and say yes thank you
that's like a way of just going uh let
the body solve what the mind can't
meaning there are some problems in your
life
that you your brain is like just let me
keep replaying it I'll just keep this on
a loop
how's all night sound
can you do all night
looking near your calendar there's
nothing but me and you and darkness
so it thinks it's doing something it
actually thinks it's helping by worrying
and I would do that and then when I
realized that there's just look there's
a humbling experience when you realize
you basically you are a block of tofu
and the thing that flavors you are your
hormones you're a chemical creature and
letting the body solve what the mind
can't means do the thing that produces
the hormone that changes the tofu
you know what I mean stop thinking your
way out of the box and you don't have to
have a treadmill go for a walk get in
nature like they say it's 15 minutes in
a green space low just the color green
lowers your blood pressure do breathing
do some uh and you do this you do this
when I'm in a good way there then talk
to me when I'm in a low way maybe I'll
forget because by the way
that's what this whole [ __ ] thing is
it's a sine wave it's remembering and
forgetting and remembering and
forgetting we just want to be like an
American corporation and only improve
only Skyrocket right those down times
when I would listen to this podcast and
be like I don't know what the [ __ ] this
guy is talking about those are essential
too it's like you're a light in a mosaic
and you blink and you turn off and you
blink and you turn off that's like
remembering and forgetting and
remembering and you're just like I just
wish I could be on all the time then if
you could zoom out and see the whole
Cosmos you would see that it's this
amazing light show that just
swirling like an incr but not even just
a screensaver it's actually making
Indiana Jones you're you're part of a
thing and even you're forgetting belongs
in the thing even your lowness belongs
in the thing and you wouldn't
you wouldn't be who you are without that
I'm not just saying oh we need to learn
and we need to suffer I'll give you an
example I pitched a TV show this week
and the first pitch was bad and then the
first pitch is great second Pitch is
great that's just how it [ __ ] goes
but we just want bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang when you tell you
the breathing technique oh yes it's just
box breathing
foreign hold for four four out hold for
four on the out so you have nothing so
do that for five minutes and try to be
anxious or
four this is the hard one it gets easier
because you'll flood your body so you
wait before you breathe in again yep
you have to slow the exhale down because
it's really tempting to really blow it
out but
I already feel calm right what is that
it's humbling man the brain wants you to
think that it's that you're it but
you're a body too let the body Let the
Body help yeah and my and Val is
wonderful at that
and a lot of teachers do you ever cry
are you a crier I wish I could cry uh
I'm not just saying that like a tough
guy you don't cry I cry I tear up I I
don't I don't get a good like oh yeah
right I don't I don't really do that
um and that's not that's not something
I'm proud or ashamed of it's just it's
just sort of what's happening right but
I Cry
like tear and like like that like all
the a lot if my heart's open right but
if I'm working a lot if I'm writing a
lot if I'm thinking a lot and I'm acting
a lot and I'm scheduling a lot the
crying is the first thing to go there's
no Pete that I love being more than
Shakespeare in the park Pete sitting on
a picnic blanket heart open fresh air
baby playing and you're just watching
the opening act which is a ballet troop
dance and you go of all the things human
beings can do that are disgusting and
ugly and wrong these people rehearsed a
dance for us and I just started crying
and I'm telling you and then my light
goes off in the Mosaic and I go [ __ ]
dance
are you are your parents alive by the
way
what if I said unfortunately I'm just
kidding but they're alive I don't mean
unfortunately Papa as they say they are
alive and they're total [ __ ] weirdos
do they see how much you've changed that
you can get a little dirty I'm sorry
what's that do they see do they mention
it do they talk to you about it do they
say you know you're you're humor now
it's completely changed or have they let
it go are they embraced your success are
they loving are they giving
um I still feel a little guilty that I
was tempted to make the dark joke of
unfortunately so I'm taking that back a
second time we know double back double
back um my my parents
I love them and
when you you actually asked you you
pinpointed exactly what I might say the
issue if I have an issue is and I do is
do they see
and the answer is is no and much of my
career has writing the book for example
is trying to get them to see I remember
writing the book and being like if I put
it in black and white and they read it
this is this is a it's a heartbreaking
thought you're like they'll have to hear
me
they'll have they'll stop seeing their
projection of the little boy in Cape Cod
digging the the with the toe-headed you
know white hair I don't know they'll
stop seeing that and they'll see a
broken complicated flawed beautiful
interesting interested curious oh boy
man not me right not boy
um
and they did read the book and there was
a brief window that's their tunnel
that's their add there was a brief
window where they they read it and they
saw it and they understood it was like
maybe one phone call and then I think
the next time I saw them after that
thinking oh it worked my there's a
chapter in my book called The heratheist
and it was when I was briefly an atheist
and my father was telling me that I was
never an atheist
wow and you're like you're not an
atheist yeah you weren't Pluto was
Indonesia she's never been an issues I'm
like there's a chapter in the book about
how I dabbled in atheism and but that's
so not who I was I was you know white
button-down shirt and khakis and the
leading in the worship team so they just
couldn't hear that but like
I feel I feel you know I feel a
Melancholy talking about it and I also
wouldn't change it now we're back to the
energy of a no if my parents did
understand me in the way that I want
them to right would I have
would I keep doing stand up or would I
keep right and and what service am I to
this Mosaic uh if all my needs are being
met I'm actually a little bit better if
I can relate to you
maybe you relate to that parent stuff or
whatever it might be loneliness right
whatever it is
um those those things are
the glue that keeps us needing each
other you know that's not people who
need people I get that more and more
people get older yeah Barbara as I get
older
I'm like yeah no it's a real gift and
you know what makes somebody like me
who's just like
you know whiteboarding movies and a
manic frenzy talking to himself alone in
his little garage uh broken this
a divorce
um even you and I uh hitting a wall and
realizing I have no podcast skills it's
like I know that's all stupid but I see
a Universe gracious enough to meet me
where I'm at and going like we know what
you actually need you think you need
Fame and money and you want what do you
want to [ __ ] you know and they go all
right
all right let's do this one we'll trick
him we'll we'll trick him it's one of my
favorite there's a expression in India
they're like because we all got into
religion because of psychedelic so many
people found some spiritual vocabulary
because I took you know mushrooms and
put all the palooza yeah in India they
said God uh America loves
materials and God loves you so much that
he came to America as a material now
whether or not you believe that it
doesn't matter if you like or don't like
God language I'm in I'm interested in a
God or a truth a universal truth
of whatever's going on here hiding in
unexpected places not just failure
that's that's a that's a big one but
also like sometimes it's hiding behind a
a good stand-up set who thought who
thought a feeling of interconnectivity
was hiding behind a good stand-up set
right I didn't I thought it was being a
bad boy turns out
this thing is again I don't want to use
God language and alienate people but
this is after you
and will keep playing hide and seek with
you and keep surprising you and Mike and
and pop out from behind my wife cheating
on me or pop out from behind right you
know right now I'm
who knows what's going to happen but
like I won't be surprised when it pops
out I'm just scared me with these jumps
hey really quick this is the end this is
called [ __ ] talking with Pete Holmes oh
these are my patrons my lovable patrons
who get back to the podcast go to
patreon.com inside you become a patron
I'll write you back but these are uh
rapid fire Sophie M which comedians
you've answered this sort of which
comedians were your favorites Growing Up
by rapid fire
Steve Martin Brian Regan uh Seinfeld
Leanne if you could only put one thing
in your bucket list what would it be and
why I don't have a bucket though
to make the biggest movie ever made oh I
guess you're right a career bucket list
could be
I don't know I don't I don't you don't
have to have one uh bucket what would I
really like to do I don't know I'm I'm
speechless little Lisa what was your
favorite sitcom when you were growing up
Family Matters and I cried real hard
when Urkel said to Laura it's like
reaching for a star you know you'll
never get it but you still reach and it
got to me and my dad's recliner like
that was probably the last good try Raj
when's the last time someone asked you
to tell them a joke just because they
knew you were a comedian how did you
handle the situation
um I it it hasn't happened too recently
but I was on set with somebody my my
friend Boomer who was the camera
operator on on how we roll he always
likes telling me jokes so it's a little
bit different and I told him this joke
which is uh two hunters in the woods
they see a bear one drops his knees and
starts praying the other one starts
tying his shoes the praying guy says
what are you doing you can outrun a bear
he says I don't have to outrun the bear
I just have to outrun you I think that's
a fine joke and I told it
Americans by the way very different
sense of humor is the rest of the world
we love jokes where someone's an idiot
and someone dies do you want to hear the
number one joke in America yes they did
it
um two Hunters always two Hunters wow
um are hunting and one the first guy
let's say Tom shoots his buddy Jake by
accident Tom shoots Jake and Jake so Tom
calls 9-1-1 and goes help help I was
hunting I shot my friend I think he's
dead operator said calm down sir first
things first make sure he's dead time
goes okay hold on bang now what that's
America's number one joke somehow they
did some survey isn't that funny we love
it but you go to even Great Britain
they're all like and the toffee was a
little bit cheeky like they're like like
a like a wordplay right we're all just
like but who's the loser
hell yes you make such comedic faces has
anyone ever told you that you they
remind you of John Ritter and has he
been a big influence in your career at
all yeah I I I wouldn't say I get that
every day but certainly every set that
I'm on and I'm honored what a genius he
was I agree I love him so much what yeah
and um
yeah obviously we didn't get to work
together but I think it's weird that I
sound like him but then we've
hypothesized if my skull is the same
shape as his I should say
hey what's what's next what are you
working on we're back to bucket list
but what are you working on well I I
like I said I just pitched a show this
week
um which is and because it went well as
part of why I'm in a really nice mood
today again I hope it gets picked up we
can't deny meeting our psychological
needs uh because that felt really nice
thank you very much
and I'm always I I like I love writing
stuff for me to be in and and that's
what I'm always doing and having done a
multicam I thought that was so fun and I
so I wrote a multicam that I just sent
to HBO HBO Max whatever uh so I'm always
writing scripts and trying to sell stuff
Writing Movies trying to for you to star
in
the shows are always for something for
me the movies are always uh typically
for somebody else right
um that's not false humility I'm just
like nobody I'm not a movie star but
that being said I mean I'm about to
pitch a movie pitches because Mark and I
are friends gonna tell mark duplas an
idea that I have I'm excited to see what
he thinks of that you're always thinking
you're always working you're always
writing
I like that's what it was so when How We
Roll got canceled
right away you you go to the next thing
that's right knife in the mouth knife in
the mouth the Rope but these days I I
stay on the burning ship a little bit
longer and go but all these people were
my friends
goodbye Mark gross goodbye Katie loves
and I get a I get singed a little bit
more than I used to it and then I swing
right
so TV ideas and and I you know it's been
a while since I've done a stand-up hour
I was going to do one before the
pandemic uh and I'd like to do that
that's that's getting to a point where I
would like to do that I'm going to be a
Montreal I'm going to be in Cancun uh
both of those are for just for laughs
and uh doing stand-up and what's your
Instagram handle that Jake handles yeah
you can follow Jake
what is your Instagram at Pete Holmes
feed Ohm's out all of them but I mean
they're all things I've approved
please buzz that but I know you can't
just do a little heroin man if I'm if I
get on uh Instagram next thing you know
I'm checking who tagged me in a picture
and it's it's Bad News Bears uh this has
been a real treat
it was my pleasure this has been really
fun you were enlightening you were fun
you were all over you were tell great
stories and then you tell some good
advice you you calmed me
if I feel this way for the rest of my
life
that would be okay I mean I'm gonna say
that to myself like see what your
nervous system does and then do the
breathing
yeah and go for a walk do you talk about
where you live
no all right well you it's a walkable
beautiful area
that's all I'm gonna say what if like
next thing you know there's 10 people
here there's 10 people in my door paint
homes
oh they're looking for me though uh
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
you today this has been awesome whoa
whoa that's what we say though that's
kind of the thing it's kind of the well
how many episodes have you done over 200
okay well then we can do a super cut of
200 times of you saying that canceled
done done the last time I say that or
just cancel the show Oh no you're done
I'm done you no I'm gonna keep doing
this I think and you're gonna keep doing
you make you make it weird you made it
you made it weird it already happened
you're gonna you're not quitting that no
and we're in I just saw we're like 700
episodes or something we've done what
yeah no wonder all homes he's running
out of people to book I'm gonna come to
you we're guests I still have guests
that you could you know people would
love to be on your show I you've done
some big podcasts you've been on big
part you but you were on Dax Shepard's
podcast yeah yep he was great yeah
you've done a lot of stuff and I didn't
know how big it was and I'm glad I
didn't but I maybe I would have tried
harder
I'm just kidding thanks for coming
right anything
no that's the end that's the way of the
podcast why does he look like race Darby
Reece Darby yeah don't Google it
okay to New Zealand are you from New
Zealand no oh no
I'm just kidding but don't Google it was
just a joke he's a good looking man yeah
you're handsome
lovely man I'm sure you enjoyed that if
you like the podcast if you like the
interview Please Subscribe and write a
review we could use your uh your help
and of course join patreon patreon.com
inside of you if you want to join and
support the podcast in more ways than
one uh the top tiers not only get a box
from me every couple months and some
other perks but they get a shout out
they get a shot out of their name at the
end of every episode so without further
Ado let's let's take it let's do it uh
Nancy D and by the way thank you again
for listening to the podcast and uh
spread the word man spread the word I'm
also in the Cameo if you want a message
or something like that uh here we go
Nancy D Leah F Sarah V little Lisa you
Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert uh
Jason W Sophie M Kristen okay Raj C
Joshua D cjp Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal
F Janelle B Kimberly
e correct Mike E Eldon supimo what's up
buddy uh 99 more Ramirez Santiago am
Chad W Leanne P Maya uh P correct Maddie
asked Melinda and Chris H Dave H Sheila
G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T nice Tom in
Liliana a Talia M Betsy uh D correct
Chad L Mary and Dan and big Stevie W
Angel M Rhiannon C Cory K Dev Nixon
Michelle a Jeremy C correct Andy t gav
you need a correct gavinator David C
John B Brandy D Camille s the chief Joey
M design
uh OTG Eugene and Leah Nikki G Corey
Katie B Patricia Heather L Jake B Megan
T Mel s Orlando C Caroline uh
uh a r r Christine s Sarah s Eric a
chain RMR Jeremy V Andrew M Zu satuichi
77 love you Oracle Chris R Michael F
Karina and Michael D Amanda are Amanda s
Jen B Kevin e Katie red Stephanie K Lena
82 and don't forget my sweet friend
Jerrell jorel
those are the top tier uh patrons we
love you I love you we love your support
I love your support and uh thank you so
much and and if you have time you want
to subscribe to another podcast that
would be talk Ville our re-watch podcast
for Ryan joins me and Tom Welling from
Smallville and we go over every episode
of the series and uh we review it and
you get to ask questions and all that so
talk Phil go uh find Us online um
talkville podcast and uh
I guess from the Hollywood Hills and in
California I am Mike Rosenberg I am Ryan
Tess and uh I just really I just want to
say I've always been a fan of Pete
Holmes and I'm really happy that he was
here it made me happy just uh I just
like it was weird that he was here I'm
still current on his podcast and I
listened to the Jason Alexander episode
and he did throw to you he did like he
did mention you so nice just in case
you're wondering he still thinks about
You Ah that's sweet gold Pete Holmes you
know I like it when Ryan really likes an
episode because he like the Judd Apatow
there's been a couple that you really
like the Odin Kirk I've been a fan of
petalum stand up it speaks to me he's
got like the energy he does it's uh yeah
if you've heard his bid on dropping a
dog it's brilliant I'm dropping a dog
that's great all right I'll check it out
all right guys be good yourself and uh
we will see you next week
[Music]